[Music]
on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
so
[Music]
good evening i'm peter morgan on censor
tonight an extraordinary exclusive
interview from the heart of europe's war
have your way boxing championship
freedom fighter vladimir klitschko on
the new fight of his life
hollywood star rupert everett and
british tv's queen of maine and robinson
but first when trans activists dressed
like ninjas blocked women from speaking
about women's rights in front of the
statue of suffrage emmeline pankhurst i
thought it was ridiculous but i wanted
to have a good faith debate with someone
i disagree with it's what this show is
all about sadly my guest had other ideas
we've bleeped it for decency this time
but it makes a powerful point about the
tribal toxic nature of a debate that too
many people are simply afraid to have
well eveline pankers the founder of the
suffragette movement is an historic
feminist icon the trans rights
protesters disagree this weekend a group
called themselves manchester trans rise
up just like paramilitaries complete
with balaclavas and forcefully stopped a
women's rights campaign group from
holding an event next to a statue of
pankhurst
they also tied the trans rights flag
around the statue's waist like an apron
well jk rowling shared the video of the
clash on twitter she said i never
expected the right side of history to
include so many people in masks
intimidating and assaulting women did
you
so can trans rights coexist with women's
rights it's all getting very emotive and
very heated a trans woman and activist
jane not her real name she's wearing a
mask to protect her identity joins me
from the site of the protest jane
welcome
hey pears it's good to hear your voice
you know well it's good to exist
honestly it's good to talk to you i want
to have a proper debate with you it's an
uncensored show so you can speak your
mind here's my question for you you're
standing at the side of where all this
went down when you see the video footage
of members of your group that day and
you were there
members of the group basically
physically assaulting a woman who was
sitting there what do you feel
i i feel annoyed because the footage is
cut and it doesn't show them storming in
shoving people over that little bit of
concrete over there which is kind of
dangerous you know you could hurt your
head quite a lot doing that it doesn't
show them shoving strangling and kicking
people um
and there's also not the you know i said
i think i sent footage to the producers
of the show i doubt that i doubt you
guys will want to show it but we've got
other footage of the same turfs that
came over and tried to assault us there
strangling and punching people at other
protests they'd like to play the victim
i think if you don't mind me saying
you're playing slight what about terry
so i only really want to know what is
your reaction to the footage we have
seen which clearly shows some of the
people that you were with
assaulting a woman i mean you can't be
happy that that is the image that your
group has now
seen around the world is doing
i mean i mean first firstly i would say
as i as i just said you know
the footage is cut you can't see the
start of the footage um and the people
dressed in black who are security to
protect members vulnerable members of
our community
they are there defending themselves
because these women came in when we were
already having a peaceful protest there
and started attacking us they will spin
it the other way jk will spin it the
other way they'll spin it the other way
but that is what happened it's just they
have a lot more money and power than us
so it's easier for them to get a reach
and message but let me ask you what i
would say you know the way the way
the way i really feel about that um
i think it's i think it was a good thing
that we came to that you said that it
was because we didn't like emily it's
although we didn't like emmeline she was
racist she was also a tory so you know
we probably wouldn't have got on with
her all right let me let me put my cards
on the table i've always supported trans
rights to fairness and equality and i
mean that sincerely i want everyone
bro well you can say bro and that's fine
you're entitled to it's an uncensored
show and you've just proven it
but but let me just say to you i always
wasn't your profile picture wasn't yours
identified
there's no point there's no point
swearing i apologize to our viewers for
your bad language this is a chance for
you to present yourself in a way where
we can have a proper debate if you've
got no interest in doing that that's
fine but i'm just going to say to you
that i've always supported trans rights
to fairness and equality my issue with
what the way this trans debate is going
is in issues like sport for example
where i think it's very unfair that
trans women should be competing against
women born to female biological bodies i
have issues about safety for women i
have issues about other areas of women's
rights do you understand
let me ask you a question do you
understand and appreciate what all these
dog whistles and talking points they're
not dog whistles
they're concerned you can't just call
everyone who disagrees with you
please
if you keep swearing
you can go and have a look at their
websites you can have a look at their
twitters
okay look look i'm trying to give you a
chance i've explained my position
what is your problem with my position
i don't really know i'm going to leave
the interview now i kind of only came on
here because i thought it would be kind
of funny but i want to say
well there you have it i did try but
honestly what's the point if someone's
going to be like that and that is the
problem with the debate around the trans
issues is that there are too many people
on the extremities hurling abuse at each
other everyone just calms down we might
actually get somewhere
dustin hoffman stayed up for three days
straight to appear tired for his role in
marathon man the great lawrence olivier
famously retorted my dear boy have you
tried acting i mean that is the job of
an actor right but some think that gay
roles for example should only be played
by gay actors and disabled roles by
disabled actors trans roles by trans
actors and presumably by that logic nazi
roles by nazi actors or is that
ridiculous is all of it ridiculous it's
a peculiar kind of method acting
zealotry and it's happening more and
more often it would consider for example
this sort of scene offensive
you know a woman said to me in the
casino today
she asked me if i was liberace's son
really
[Music]
matt damon and michael douglas both
obviously in liberation both acting
now my next guest is a gay man who says
his career suffered because hollywood
that great liberal bastion of tolerance
and fairness couldn't grasp or tolerate
or be fair about his ability to play it
straight is of course direct to producer
movie superstar rupert everett loving
his feet
when you watch as a gay man you watch
that scene from from candelabra the
liberace film
to me is a straight guy it seemed very
sensitively done very realistic
and more than that for me watching that
film i was very moved by the amount of
work and detail that those two actors
bothered
to put into their research the way they
attacked the roles um i was i was i was
elated by it um
and there's there's many uh examples of
of fantastic uh straight actors playing
great gay roles and then there's some
less good and um i think the question is
more why can't gay actors play straight
roles right that's the thing because
what happened to you was fascinating
because when you were deemed to be
straight you got all these romantic
leads in hollywood everyone loved you
and you were the hugh grant of your if
you don't mind the comparison i would
find that pretty repellent by the way no
i've said it it's out there uh you're
the hugh grant of your day and then you
came out and suddenly it was like right
no more work for you son we can't have
you as a straight romantic lead i don't
think it was actually quite like that to
be honest but um the thing that was very
frustrating when when i had my kind of
big hollywood moment which was
playing a a gay best friend and being
gay uh i it was at that point very
difficult to graduate i knew i had to
try and graduate to playing something
else apart from just that role
and and it felt that it was more or less
impossible so my question is
i don't think uh gay actors should just
play the gay roles i think but the gay
actors should be able to play the
straight roles too i think some straight
guys play great gay roles and it's not
it's not just about the gay roles and
gay actors and so on i want to show some
pictures here from other movies tom
hanks for example
in philadelphia actually is an example
of that but tom hanks in philadelphia to
me it was an incredibly powerful movie
which shot an unbelievably bright light
on the issue of aids and what tom hanks
did i thought he played the role
magnificently but more importantly he
brought tremendous numbers of eyeballs
to watch it because he's tom hanks and
it was a riskier period to do that as
well i mean when michael douglas and
matt damon did the candelabra movie
things have changed substantially yes
when he did that film uh it wasn't
really a subject that people wouldn't
would a gay man have played that any
more powerfully and was there a gay
actor out at the time for example
who would have got the box office
success that tom hanks brought and
therefore the light that was shot on the
issue this is the other question you
know people forget that hollywood is a
business uh so for example when scarlett
johansson uh
was uh stopped from playing uh a trans
role yeah uh
there wasn't there simply wasn't a trans
actress at that point big enough to
sustain a 50-60 million dollar movie i
found that was a mistake of the trans
community because there were probably
lots of other trance roles in the film
that would have been played by uh trans
actresses and uh
scarlett johansson wasn't going to be
doing some portrait that was anti-trans
so i felt it was slightly
blinkered attitude eddie redmayne had a
similar thing with the danish girl you
know he got into trouble for that from
the trans community but your question
there is
he started the role as a boy so so who's
going to play the boy
and the problem with that movie in the
end is it was just dull right which is a
it's another a crime altogether but
eddie redmayne also played stephen
hawking for example and that was an
amazingly powerful fantastic role and
again shot a huge light on that
particular affliction with stephen
hawking had and i felt did it
brilliantly now i don't know why it
would need to be somebody who's got that
condition that stephen hawking had motor
neuron disease or a variant of it to be
as effective or more effective than
eddie redmayne well i don't think it
could have been because someone with
that condition just wouldn't be able to
uh do you know to be out there on the
set from six in the morning till late at
night i just played a role of someone
who'd had a very bad stroke uh it would
be impossible for someone who'd had a
very bad stroke to really right start
working and that's the problem isn't it
once you once you take the last they
wanted to right but if you take the
logic to its logical end well you have
to be a murderer to play a mill this is
my point so here we go anthony hopkins
who played hitler right i mean are we
legitimately saying that if you're going
to play hitler now in a movie you have
to be a nazi similarly the sopranos the
sopranos
are we going to say now that they all
had to be the senior sopranos genuine
members of the mob right but on the
other on the other side piers you've got
to remember yes of course there
shouldn't be we shouldn't be making
rules about this yes of course it's
great uh for gay actors who've had quite
a hard time you know historically uh to
be playing more roles to be getting the
game it's quite frustrating uh i was
frustrated i remember going to see colin
firth in um
the film by tom ford and he made a
screening i thought well thanks colin
that's the end of my career because you
know that role really should have been
mine yeah yeah yeah and then uh um and
uh so you know there's a frustration
about that of course uh and there's also
a point i do get which is what um some
disabled uh actors have made the point
to me that there's not the opportunity
at the grassroots level you know for
them to get on the right ladder to get
them into a position where they may get
these big roles because they're not
perceived to be big enough box office
stars they find the system is a bit
oppressive to people uh and i get that i
get the fact that maybe disabled actors
do not get the same opportunities i get
that too but i mean the thing is what
how is the business meant to change for
that you know i mean it's it's quite
complicated no i you know it's really
frustrating uh if you're a disabled
actor and uh it's um
but i don't think the answer to richard
iii
in stratford-on-avon for example which
greg
um the outgoing
head of the rsc said that it can only
now be played by disabled people i just
thought it was ridiculous to say that i
think it would be love i'd love to see
it played by a disabled actor by the way
but i don't see why
uh it's one of the great roles that
actors want to play you know acting is
acting movies and television and cinema
are a particular article but it's not
the thing that ultimately
acting should mean what it says on the
team it's acting that you as an actor
one of the best in the business you
should be able to play any role actually
let me just um while i've got you i'm
curious about your view we've been
talking about the show about cancer
culture this sort of rather insidious
phenomenon which has raised its ugly
head you've always been very outspoken
you've always been pretty uncensored in
all the time i've known you what do you
feel about the society
that we now operate in these eggshells
everyone feels they have to tread on i
think it feels like uh the stasi to be
honest i think it feels incredibly
repressive i don't think it gets
it manages to achieve the aims
that uh that it's that it's after for
example
i don't know
uh
i've never met jk rowling for example um
and i've never read her books and um
i have but i i'm willing to bet that
before this all happened she was not
someone who was anti-transsexual no uh
not remotely everything about it nothing
so but now she might be it's reached a
point where someone's got to start
trying to make peace uh among these
between these two groups and i think the
thing we tend to forget is that in the
kind of 24-hour history of humanity
these two million years the women's
movement only started literally three
seconds ago in that whole thing yes so
our brains are hardwired to something
very anti-women too in a way so the
trance movement has come right on the
edge of the woman's movement and in fact
they're probably when you look at it
from further in advance the same thing
we do you're right though we need we
need to bring the extremities of these
debates because i don't believe people
are trans these people i i it's
dangerous to call people
uh turfs when they're not because you
make them into it jk rowling to me is
not transphobic she wants to safeguard
women's rights and she should be
applauded for doing so
we run out of time great to talk to you
thank you very much tremendous shaver
mike so are you really good to see you
thank you thank you for coming thank you
very much good to see you i want to play
rupert everett in a movie actually i
want you to play me in a movie i mean
that would be good actually i could
you'd be good as me if you just you know
i've lost some weight
going to see it take care oh he's off
it's storming off oh am i meant to no
not yet it's fine i don't know if you
want it it's the damn thing you can sit
there for a bit
well that says the next i speak to
former world heavyweight champion
vladimir klitschko from ukraine a
country ravaged by war has cost tens of
thousands of lives of his country
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
vladimir klitschko is famous across the
planet as the former world heavyweight
boxing champion he's now fighting for
the freedom of his home country ukraine
in a remarkable exclusive interview he
told me how he's prepared to dive for
his country in the new fight of his life
i would
say that this battle is definitely
the most important
of our lives
of the
ukrainians
when they were
expecting to be attacked as as it
happened on 24th of february
and this senseless war
has
taken
thousands of
lives
destroyed infrastructure in the country
and still going on the fights are still
going on while we're talking
and every night
every day there are rocket attacks up to
2 000 rockets had been launched from
belarus and russia
to
destroy our life
and i want to use just one one moment of
of
of this monologue
and say thank you to great britain
boris johnson
that has stepped in he was trying
a lot from the early beginning
to find
the way how he can talk
to putin how he can prevent the first
steps that unfortunately were made and
the lines were crossed are you prepared
if it comes to it to
lose your life to fight for your country
i asked mike
myself this question when russian forces
were in outskirts of the city
and if i wouldn't be ready for it i
would have left the city of kiev with
almost 5 million people like a sponge
it's big city and busy city was empty
you could hear the
explosions constant
explosion because the fights were going
on in the outskirts of the city
and
you must count with anything while
you're in cave or in ukraine with
anything
even now and this question is basically
everyone in ukraine ukrainian or not and
as you know their journalists your
colleagues journalists been killed
precisely with sniper shots
and lost their lives if you're in
ukraine you must
you must know that that could be your
last moment in life
last trip in life and
are you ready to give up anything you
have for the country and freedom and
that's the question that
millions of ukraine's asking and the
answer is yes because you could do
anything for your children anything for
your country anything for your parents
anything that
that you love
and that's something that just
cannot be in a different in a different
way
what is your message to putin
i've been asked this question many times
in multiple
occasions and interviews
it's
just
you know
there's no particular
line that
could do anything
to put him
to change his life
or to a person in this case
and change his opinion or or stop this
war
it's just in mad person's mind and how
you can convince a madman i don't even
know
and there is nothing to communicate
because obviously what was coming from
russian side
is a lie
when they said we're never gonna offend
anyone invade anyone it was just
happening
and this is in multiple cases
as soon as
russia put him his army or foreign
ministers or anybody involved were
making statements
that was exactly the opposite
so how can we communicate i don't see
even sense or reason
there is just
one line
that
not just putin but
the entire world
must take it seriously
stop
this
senseless
war
and this is on putin
and as well as on the free world because
without you support and help and if
you're gonna keep
standing silently
and just observing what is going on in
ukraine
blood is on your hands too
because you do nothing about it
if you do nothing about it and that's
why stale out
to stop
this war
i'm not going to get into details but
stop this war
as soon as the war is going to be
stopped
life's going to be saved
no emotion what is what is your view
of what should be done for example
with russian sports
people uh athletes and so on there is a
view that they should all be banned from
any competition there's another view
that only the team
playing
under the russian flag should be banned
and individuals should be allowed to
continue what is your view as one of the
great
sporting champions certainly in my
lifetime
on economical side
isolation of russia
on different
points of it gas oil coal
no ships can park at any ports
they should understand that the world is
against
this senseless war
against
not just with warding and sanctions but
in reality nothing but isolation at
least
next olympic games
i think
that iuc should ban
the russian team now
the war is going on
they cannot participate at next olympic
games they cannot participate at any
athletic events
because
this war
is represented by russia
so atlas representing russia and there
is definitely connection
and i believe that this is going to be
the message and that's exactly the
answer for the question what would you
say to mr putin it's really saying is
cheap now
action speaks louder than words
isolation
isolation and this isolation speaks
louder than any line
in any word
because isolation is painful
yes it's going to be painful for
athletes it's going to be painful for
economy it's going to be painful for
everybody and anybody that is involved
with russia
silently
trading with russia
supporting their financially with this
in this trade because the money that
russia is getting and filling up their
budget
they're getting and producing more
weapons and financing their soldiers
that today killing us ukrainians
and that must be stopped with isolation
and atlas is not an exception
vladimir when this war is over and one
day it will be over
do you hope to
get back to boxing again there's been
lots of speculation that that may be
what you want to do
you're going to put smile on my face i i
just realized recently that i haven't
smiled a lot in the past
80
to 3 days and
you just said something about sports
because that puts me in somewhere my
comfort zone because that's where my
passion is and
and honestly i was i was thinking like i
should i should just
take tyson fury and tweet
last dance question mark
since he wants to retire and we
and we uh we supposed to have this
rematch and then and i was thinking
about it you know i didn't do it because
my mind was in totally different
or now a different world but it just you
know after
getting those news that um he defended
the title and he is uh
retiring and i wish him the best it must
be hellish what you're all going through
in ukraine and the moment i mentioned
something which took you back to your
life before this your face lit up you
know the last time i saw you was at the
alfred dunhill links golf tournament in
october last year
and i remember you you were celebrating
one night with andre chefchenko the
great ukrainian football player
and life seemed pretty good for all of
us right then and life has changed very
dramatically now and i very much hope
that you know come
the autumn this war is over
you've got your country back you've won
and i get to see you again up in
scotland on the links there because that
would be a sign
of i think a reward for the astonishing
courage that you and the ukrainian
people have shown
fingers
crossed hopefully the peace in ukraine
will
come sooner than later
thank you for hanging me
mr morgan it was great seeing you you
know what it's just from tv ukraine
it's been such an honor to interview and
robinson is british tv royalty in fact
ferocious one-liners has hosted the
weakest link under the nickname the
queen amin she's certainly seldom been
sensitive and she made no exception with
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
and robinson is british tv royalty in
fact her ferocious one-liners has hosted
the weakest link under the nickname the
queen of mean she's certainly seldom
been censored and she made no exception
with me
when you see politicians who can't
answer what is a woman yeah a what do
you feel about that what is the answer
the answer is a woman is someone with a
vagina do you need to say that again it
is somebody with a vagina
and i can now be cancelled well a woman
every dictionary will say is an adult
female adult human female that's it it's
not complicated but they don't say that
i think it's so disappointing when the
leader of the labour party always has to
think for three weeks before he makes
that decision on anything
just mumbling is that cooper the same i
don't want to be drawn into that
it it is so unfair it is so it is the
first time we've never been able to have
a debate you and i are having one here
because we're fearless
but
name me when the last debate was on the
bbc about trans well when you see what
happened to jk rowling yeah this is what
puts people off because you know she's
been absolutely terrorized let me ask
you about something else that was in the
news today i thought i thought of you
immediately
do you think it'd be awful i do think of
you often oh no because actually we go
back a long way and also we both worked
at the daily mirror for many years
we weren't newspapers
who crossed the divide to become
television get on with it exactly what
were you going to say the the uk today
had the biggest ever lottery winners 184
million people they're not as rich as
you are well i'm going to come to your
wealth in a minute let's just see what
they had to say watch this
jess hadn't had a great night's sleep so
i thought do i wake her up don't i wake
her up what what do i do so i just sat
there for a minute
trying to take it all in and i thought
well i'll give her because it's only 20
minutes i'll give her an extra 20
minutes till her alarm goes off
so you waited 20 minutes after knowing
he won 194 million didn't want to wake
his wife up um what i was struck by when
i watched that and i because i knew you
were coming on yeah it's the old thing
are they going to be happy
with 184 million there'll be loads of
people right now suffering from the
economic crisis go of course they will
but so many of these lottery winners
actually find that when they get the
grass it's not greener and it's so much
better to give money to people who've
already got money because they're
trained like you me
but does it bring happiness it obviously
stops the the agony and turmoil of not
having money which is an appalling thing
for people but does having a lot of
money hundreds of millions do you think
that kind of wealth in your experience
of meeting very wealthy people and being
well off yourself does it bring
happiness not necessarily but i think
i'd rather be miserable and rich right
than miserable and poor wouldn't you
well i think yeah i think poverty is the
worst thing you can experience as a
human being because to not be able to
feed your children so on is the worst
thing but i have met a lot of wealthy
people who are miserable and boring and
they always want more there's always
somebody around who's got more and also
you've been in los angeles as much as i
have you find they have these huge
houses and they all live in one tiny
room yes and they watch the television
and the rest of the house looks like the
four seasons everything's beige
and they never use it what advice would
you give these lottery winners 184
million to spend well i'd give them time
actually they need time
and they keep they need so stephen
daldry once said to me when he'd become
quite rich from his first movie billy
elliot
he said if you're looking after
relatives
never give them a set amount every year
or always make them worry they might not
get anything from you next year
what do you make of of cancel culture of
do you accept it you accept it it has to
exist i couldn't close you don't care no
it doesn't cost me any money does it if
anyone cancels me
right and you're not on social media
right you don't do any of it no why
well no one's paying me to do that
why would i do it but what do you think
the people
i find it amazing in a democracy like
the uk for example or america these
great bastions of democracy people are
terrified of saying what they think now
well in case they get destroyed but you
are never off your phone i watched you
in rehearsal right you're doing a bit of
rehearsal and you're back on your feet
and you do a lot of social media well
it's also a great research tool
obviously i was checking in but you also
you're a big emailer yes yeah
and you're on twitter presumably yes
yeah and you do instagram yes okay do
you mind being cult
do you mind being cancelled well it's
funny i had a little experience of it of
good morning talk about you yeah
but i lost my job on good morning
britain for expressing an honestly held
opinion what a great great future you
suddenly have yeah it was a great career
move but actually in the moment i was
pretty appalled that i i was not able to
express myself honestly i had to then
depart a job i loved i found it a weird
new phenomenon but you know what pierce
the nation cried
have you got to read you know i'm quite
proud of you because people are
incredibly fond of you
because you're fearless thank you yeah
you don't know what to say can we give
anne a bit more time please i'm ready i
think the interview is beginning to
really go the way i hoped
before i let you go you've left left
countdown um which a lot of fans will be
very upset about you
you were brilliant on it i've read the
sort of tea leaves it looked like the
people weren't getting on great would
that be fair all of you no i think i
mean susie dent is great um rachel riley
is completely brilliant at
the uh maths you just didn't get on well
no i didn't not get on but some
performers like a lot of noise around
them before they go on air and others
like me who are trying to get the
contestants to remember what their
hobbies are
would like some quirk while she's doing
that not two minutes so it was important
to me that we took our mic off so that
um i could have them what i love about
you is many things but you you're
fearless i love your outspokenness i
love the interviews you give they always
make me laugh but they also inspire me
because you've got a tremendous work
ethic and i guess the obvious question
what what are you gonna do next you got
any ideas i thought um if you upset them
here i could just move in
[Laughter]
you know what we could take you and talk
tv you'd be fantastic yeah
is the money good enough
look at this suit yeah
and lovely to see you so good looking a
real pleasure thank you you can come
back can we book down immediately for
next week uh it's lovely to see you look
you're fantastic and it's always a joy
to have you really appreciate it
a threat to the huge global fashion
brand of vogue
from this pub what yes the star in at
vogue a tiny 150 year old pub based in
the village of vogue in rural cornwall
landlords mark and rachel graham got a
threatening letter from vogue magazine
publishers conde nast warning them the
confused customers might think it's all
part of the fashion giant conde nast
told them as far as the general public
is concerned a connection between your
business and ours is likely to be
inferred please would you like to let us
know whether you will change your
company's name how dumb does vogue think
the pub customers are exactly well
content has thankfully eventually gone
to his senses and back down my husband
and wife landlord team mark and rachel
graham so they may now start a local
parish newsletter and call it vogue
magazine and they join me now from the
starring vogue welcome to both of you
i've got to say when i first heard about
this i thought it was
a joke a windup that vogue this
wonderful global magazine fashion empire
would be threatened by a little pub what
was your reaction
oh good evening pierce yeah mine was
exactly the same as you i upped the
letter and i thought it was one of the
customers
having a joke having a bit of a laugh
until i
did some research looked into it and
found out no they were serious they
really did think a little village pub in
cornwall is going to be confused with a
fashion magazine and rachel i mean it's
obviously very flattering if they think
that you're
you know an offshoot
of this wonderful fashion
uh
iconic empire were you personally
flattered do you think they'd seen you
in some dazzling dresses or something
uh no i wouldn't have thought so now
no i don't i don't do a lot of fashion i
don't i don't even read the magazine and
a lot of people around here don't
actually say
well has it been a good talking point
for the locals uh mark because obviously
everyone's been having a good laugh i
think reading about it but to actually
live there and go in the pub must have
been hilarious the last few days
well it's it's a bit mixed actually most
people think it's hilarious and what
they're doing but they're you know
there's a good few people that
cornwall is a very proud county very pro
came to him they see this there's um
a company like vogue trying to take over
and subjugate the little guy and have a
go at the cornish and it's our name
we've had it for ages you know um
apparently it's in the doomsday book
vogue so there's a few that think um you
know we should actually take vote to
court and make them change their name
though
that is the cornish spirit i know and
love i think you should maybe try that
be quite funny oh yeah we like a bit of
rebellion down here
and obviously vogue is known for it we
want to go that far
vogue is known for its style are you
definitely got a style here we've got
our own i was going to ask you what is
what is the cornish style in vogue at
the moment
oh just just the normal i would say the
same with the country just relax chilled
and easy anything chilled and easy
laid back definitely laid back well i
love that part of the world i've not
been down i've not been down to cornwall
during the pandemic i can't wait to get
down there i think it's a very funny
story well done you for sticking to your
guns vogue can do one frankly and uh
next time i'm down in cornwall i'm
coming to the star in vogue and have a
what's the local brew what's the best
pain
well i'm drinking skinners uh i've been
enjoying them for them a long time ago
so skinner's a churro is um one of the
popular ones or tintagel from just up
their own i'll come another skinners
with you uh mark rachel thank you for
joining me really appreciate it
well uncensored next he's boldly gone
where no 90 year old has gone before
star trek icon william shatner on how
blasting into space shifted his
perspective about humanity he's live
after the break the great man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
after decades of voyaging through
galaxies and science fiction star trek
icon william shatner reached a final
frontier in a rocket built by
billionaire amazon boss jeff bezos with
his blue origin it took leaving this
earth and being blasted into space in
order for the 90 year old to see what
i've been saying for a while
everybody in the world needs to see
there is mother of earth and comfort but
what you see is black
what you have given me
is the most profound experience
i can imagine it's uh i'm so
filled with emotion about what just
happened i i just it's extraordinary
extraordinary
and william shatner joins me now william
great to have you on the program thank
you so much for joining piers morgan
unsensitive
tech appears you know when i was young
uh and i've been pretty young i used to
love star trek the tv series and it
taught me in many ways a lot about space
travel and i found it fascinating as
well as entertaining when i watched you
get so emotional
about actually going to space it made me
quite emotional watching you
this guy i'd grown up with
actually achieving this dream and
finding it so breathtakingly moving what
was it like for you
well that you know you've asked an
interesting question i was emotional but
and you were emotional what were you
emotional about i was really emotional
about watching a guy who when i was
young was this great tv icon i loved
star trek and i learned about space
travel really through the show
and then to see you this fictitious
character that i knew from television
the real man going up in space and being
so moved i thought i just found that
very moving yes
i'm glad to hear that but
for me the emotion wasn't like oh i'm up
in space and i i played a space uh
commander so many years ago
for me
when i look back at earth and i've only
discovered this hours after when i came
down i'm thinking why am i so emotional
and what i discovered for myself was
that i was grieving for what we've done
to this
earth this tiny little rock and and you
see the tiny little rock
i could see the beginning of the
curvature of the earth i could make a
circle and do the circumference of the
earth that's how tiny we're
insignificant this insignificant rock
with these insignificant ants on the
rock
and yet it's beautiful and it's our life
and we're destroying it and i didn't
really comprehend
what my
tears were for
until i had time to assess it and then i
realized i was grieving
for the earth and what we've done
because as you know
i was going to say on that point i mean
i think there are two things we've done
it seems to me we've slowly ruined the
planet you know physically ruined it
with our
consumption but also it seems to me that
we've we've lost a lot of people lost
all sense of perspective and that maybe
when you were up in space looking down
and seeing this tiny thing earth that we
need to get back to
common sense to a sense of perspective
about what really matters in life would
you agree with that
uh
well that's philosophically right that's
correct that's like a really good idea
in the midst of driving an electric car
somewhere uh that that that's a great
idea
what i saw
is the enormity of what we've done
what we've done to five billion years of
evolution and and all these beautiful
things that have evolved and are gone
forever
five billion years brought whatever it
is is now extinct
it's gone
and
dimly in my mind i was looking back at
earth and grieving not only for the
things that are gone
but the things that are going
and in the very near future the things
that
will go right and it was all that we are
doing nothing
about
what this tsunami you know that
apparently in hilo some years ago there
was a tsunami and the people didn't
recognize it and the water goes out
apparently and they're the people oh
look at that the water's gone out
there's fish there they were not aware
that this giant wave was coming to
hawaii to kill a lot of people there's a
giant wave coming our way we see aspects
of it now with
all the storms and and and droughts and
things
but that's nothing compared to what our
children are going to face in the next
several years prince william um who's
actually big on the environment but
prince william was quite critical of
your trip and the other
what he calls tourism space travel trips
he thinks it's billionaires running
around wasting time and money they
should be focused on more important
things what did you think of that
well you know that's that's
that's yeah you know in if you look at
it yes that's true there's all that
energy going to to to go up and come
down
but bezos idea
is to get polluting industries
up into the sky
and
and let them pollute you know 300 miles
above us and and
and try and uh bring the earth back to
what it was it's a beautiful idea when i
was talking to him i said but that's
going to take a hundred years and we
don't have 100 years and he said
and this is what the prince should
understand
you've got to have hope
without hope you have nothing
so
we're cling to a hope but we've got to
do something about the carbon dioxide
and the methane to say
you know two things that are polluting
us well you talk of hope i can only say
that if when i get to 90 i hope i look
half as good as you do william shatner
piers you've got the bone structure to
be a hundred 102 and look as handsome as
you are today
it's fantastic to talk to you uh
honestly you're one of my tv heroes and
a great guy and i really appreciate you
joining the show tonight thank you very
much
thank you a pleasure to talk to you
what a man what a legend
captain james t kirk well generations of
children and the scouts and girl guides
have been honored with badges for honing
their life skills in orienteering
camping navigation yeah real skills now
they have a brand new challenge
[Music]
yes the new challenge for british girl
guides for which they actually get
badges lording their success is walking
to the chip shop
the new badge features a smiling lady
french fry and hiking boots happily
striding to a chip shop while hungrily
brandishing a fork kids can get another
badge for eating a pizza i'm not joking
all this is the uk is set to become the
fattest country in europe with 37
percent of the nation obese by 2030 the
official goal guiding twitter account
says it's absolutely worth teaching and
celebrating adding the recipients of
being honored in for their independence
enjoying the outdoors money management
and following directions following
directions really to a chip shop judging
by the fat record in this country we
have no problem finding chip shops
that's it from me
make sure your chips are nice and greasy
whatever you're up to make sure it's
unsettled
[Music]
[Music]
i'm ian collins and you're watching talk
tv the hope of straight talking
what makes me angry people who own
reptiles make me why would you own a
snake when you live on the 14th floor of
a flat in maidstone that's just
ridiculous on a more serious level what
makes me agree with the middle class
intelligentsia uh the kind of guardian
easter characters that report to walk in
the shoes of ordinary people that
actually haven't got a clue what it's
really like
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm zora sugelman latest
reports are suggesting the prime
minister met privately with sue gray to
discuss the handling of her party gate
report it says boris johnson is set to
be named alongside around 30 others in
the civil servants long-awaited report
which is expected to be published in the
full week next week cases of monkey pox
in the uk have more than doubled to 20.
the world health organization today held
an emergency meeting to discuss the
viral infection
and ukraine's president vladimir
zelensky has called a russian attack on
a cultural center in kharkiv evil seven
people were injured in the attack
including an 11 year old child it says
russia's defense ministry claims the
final ukrainian troops at the as of
style steel plant in mariopol have now
surrendered
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you